let me get to uh charles barkley who uh
of course is the star of tnt
chuck good morning how are you good
morning brother how are you doing
i'm doing okay i was worried about you
last night they were picking on you
and i thought if kenny was a little bit
bigger you might have popped him
no man we just have fun you know it's
it's crazy right now working every day
so we're just trying to make sure people
watching and enjoying the show
the basketball has been good but are you
out of the prediction business
uh for today i'm gonna take some time
off i'm old for three on guaranteed so
i'm gonna take some time off
yeah i'm gonna definitely take some time
off yeah but you have to have something
attached to your guarantee like if it
doesn't happen then
this has to happen well the good thing
about my guarantees you know i'm not in
one of those states where i can bet
on the on the app right now for fanduel
so uh
and i'm not near a casino so right now
right right now they're just words
well that's probably a good thing uh i
did love the blazers prediction just
from the fact that you were so strong
with it
and then shaq broke your broom when you
said there was going to be a sweep
that was good tv yeah man you know the
blazers
looks like they've run out of gas but
the main thing the lakers are making
shots
you know they were the worst three-point
shooting team in the nba all season but
the last three games
they're making shots i mean we knew a.d
and lebron were gonna play great
but now they're making shots the kids
can they keep doing it
i mean because even though they're on a
hot streak
you know their their track record says
they're the worst three-point shooting
team
in the nba all season yeah i don't know
if portland is going to
solve everything for the lakers to me it
was kind of the perfect team to face
because they don't play any defense
but i don't know what's going to happen
this next round i mean utah has been
surprisingly
good considering conley left the bubble
bogdanovic had the uh
wrist surgery there so i don't know who
who do the lakers want to face between
uh denver and utah wait uh
don't they play the rockets next
reggie reggie was saying yesterday that
that the lakers facing utah would uh be
great
well well first of all utah i i can't
remember the brackets right off top of
my head
mclevin check that for me did see if
chuck is right yeah b
lakers rockets lakers rockets okay or
lakers okc
okay yeah and listen it all depends on
westbrook
but they be favored over the rockets
listen that denver series
if demo plays in the defense i picked
denver to win that series
uh they played great last night but um
that's
still a pickum series in my opinion yeah
i'm trying to figure out
what the rockets i mean that philosophy
you live by it you die by it
you know do you i mean they'd pass up
twos chuck
to take away you know what listen they
have a style they're gonna go with it
you know in the third quarter the other
night they made eight straight threes to
start
and they went out to a good lead and
then down the stretch they were five for
26.
they were actually four for 26. they
threw one up at the buzzer
that went in it didn't count i mean they
counted so
they were four really four for 26.
listen
it was great if it works but i think
shooting a basketball is probably the
hardest part of basketball
and you're just gonna go through streaks
where you can't make them you know that
year they against the warriors
they miss like 30 in a row and my kid
my question is can they against an elite
team an elite defensive team
can they make four out of seven days and
i just think that's too hard to do
yeah i'm with you on that i think
they're a great regular season curiosity
but when it gets to the postseason i
just think that system is flawed
because their shooters aren't as good as
golden state shooters and and golden
state plays defense as well
when they were having their title runs
well and also
i think you put so much pressure on one
guy
james is the best one-on-one player i've
probably ever seen
you know no disrespect to michael kobe
but
james harden when i said it a few years
ago everybody said i was crazy now they
know
this guy is unstoppable one-on-one
but the problem is you always get tired
i mean i remember when i was living
i mean i live in phoenix i thought steve
nash
wore down every year i i believe that i
just think it's too hard to do that
uh for two straight months
and the same with iverson you know the
these guys who have to carry that every
single night
people don't realize a the pressure and
just the energy
that you you know you exert trying to do
that every single night
well and you know dan one thing that
i've said is
you have to do it every single night you
think about it
lebron had a bad game and they still
beat portland
uh you know uh you know jamal murray's
had some bad like
james hart is the only player in the nba
who has to play great for his team to
win every night because he has the ball
100 of the time he has to
play great every single night there's no
other player in the nba
who has to play great for their team to
win
i'd argue luca has to play great for
that team to win
well he but i'm saying he can get uh you
know
the other day when he scored the 40
points that was fantastic but if he got
25 points
they could still win james has to get in
my
just in my opinion james has to get a
minimum
of 30 a night for that team because he
like he's the guy especially with no
russ
yeah i i understand what you're saying
and speaking of
uh luca last night you know the clippers
blow them out but you know there's that
moment where morris steps on
luca's bad ankle now
if you're the nba do you read anything
it's hard to read intent into something
charles but
given the physicality and what's
happened with the clippers
to luca and what they've said and done
do you say or do anything to the
clippers
if you're the commissioner you know the
play did not look good
uh in my opinion because if you look at
the play the balls are
the play is already dead the ball's in
the basket
there's no reason for him to be going
toward that basket you would actually be
getting back on defense
i don't want to get on your show and
accuse somebody playing dirty but i will
say this
there was no reason for him to be going
toward luca in that situation
i mean the ball is in the basket and
you normally would be getting back on
defense it's not a good look
i mean uh adam's gonna have to take a
look at that but it doesn't look good
i'm not gonna lie
yeah once again it's hard to read intent
in there but i agree with you i said
that about 15 minutes ago
morris is not making a basketball move
there's no reason for him to be going
towards
luca because there it's an inbounds pass
there
and then he steps on the back of his
ankle there so
i mean dan listen i don't ever want to
get on tv and accuse somebody
doing something dirty but i'm saying
listen
the evidence does not look good there's
no reason
i mean the balls in the back and i've
looked at it a hundred times
i'm exaggerating obviously i'm like okay
the ball is in the basket
uh he's not even close to the lane when
the ball goes in the basket
and then he runs in the lane and steps
on the guy ankle
it's not a very good look what do you
think of the clippers right now
last night change anything well i think
they saw the lakers play
uh with great energy and effort and
they're like you know what
we can't beat that team the way we're
playing
listen i think that 100 percent of
people in the world
going into the season thought it was
going to come down to the lakers and
clippers
i think it's fair to say it's pretty
much still going to come down to the
lakers and clippers in the west
you know uh denver's really inconsistent
and bad defensively
i think utah the loss of mcdonough is
the really big deal
you know i i i thought about donovan's
play that was a pickum series
uh so i don't think uh anything changed
my mind it's gonna be the lakers and the
clippers
uh in the western conference finals in
my opinion
charles barkley the hall of famer tnts
inside the nba
joining us on the program greek freak is
defensive player of the year
now he's going to be the mvp it's
can you be the best player in the sport
but not be
the face of a sport
well listen what he's accomplished at
this age
uh is incredible and i tell you what dan
he's such a great kid
his humility you know i think about last
year when we had him on the
awards show and he won mvp he was crying
i mean even last night when we gave him
the defensive player of the year he was
emotional he's a great kid
you know i heard you guys talking about
earlier one of your poll questions
i mean he's only 26. yeah
you know michael jordan didn't win his
first championship and he until he was
28.
uh i think the same thing with lebron
you know it i get frustrated when these
guys in the media not you
but the guys in the media tell me well
if he don't win the championship this
year he's got to leave milwaukee
i'm like nobody said that to michael
jordan
when he would uh you know like i i love
the way these guys like oh
he hasn't wanted he's got to leave
milwaukee to win the championship
i hope he's wins the championship it'd
be great for the nba
i hope he stays in milwaukee i'd hate to
see him join the super team because
you know that dilutes the nba but what
he's accomplished so far is incredible
and i would love for him to be the face
of the nba
because he's such a great kid and a hell
of a player
whose reputation has gone up the most in
the bubble damien
doncic jamal murray donovan mitchell
well that's a really difficult question
and a great question
you know listen i i think that
dame was awesome you know that team
man they got a lot of talent i hate that
they ran out of gas
i wish they could be together for the
entire season
because they would have been a one or
two seed
uh but what donovan has done so far
and what luca's done man i don't i don't
listen the nba has got some young
some great players they're really close
to being superstars
i mean man i feel really good about what
we're going in the future
but i don't think you can say i'll take
any one of those guys you mentioned man
to be honest with you i mean they've
been greed in the bubble hey listen i
want to give adam silver a shout out
let me tell you something man i i have
been on the record
i thought there was no way this thing
would work
i thought it was no way this thing
worked same thing with my boys in hockey
shout out to the tampa bay lightning
hell of a game last night my boy john
cooper is a coach i was watching the
whole game
but let me tell you something i
thought there was no way this thing
could work without a bunch of positive
tests but shout out to gary bettman and
adam silver
and also to the players for for staying
really
i mean we had a couple of hiccups but i
cannot believe we made it this far with
no positive test
now that's going to change the next
round when we start bringing in families
and things like that
but we've already been farther than i
ever thought we would get
and also paul george said he was in a
dark place he was battling
depression in the bubble there
yeah you know i'm not sure what that was
about i
i i have already talked to a couple of
players and they were complaining about
the food
and things like that i'm not sure when
you
listen people who are living in the
pandemic
who've lost their jobs you know we got a
hurricane
battling down on uh houston the two
hurricanes
uh you know so i don't think guys making
millions of dollars to be worried just
because they're stuck
in a place where they can go fishing and
play golf and play basketball to make
millions of dollars
that's not a dark place uh the thing
that just happened in wisconsin
uh the thing that's happening with this
pandemic all these people losing their
job those people are in a dark place
we are the luckiest people in the world
to dribble a stupid basketball to make
millions of dollars
we're never in a dark place i i i just
think we need to be careful what we
complain about
i mean those people who get ready to get
hit with those two hurricanes in the
middle of a pandemic
that's awful man my thoughts are to
those people
you brought up uh what happened in
wisconsin with uh jacob blake and there
was talk yesterday that some of these
players were looking at maybe
sitting out you know the raptors a
couple of fred van vliet
uh that maybe they would sit out a game
in protest of what happened when uh
he was shot seven times this might come
down to
does lebron like i don't know how much
pressure is on lebron to do something
because when lebron does it then
everybody else does it but
do you think that that there's a
potential of these players maybe sitting
out a game
as a show of protest with what happened
yeah i'm not sure what that would do to
be honest with you
uh uh i think they got an amazing
platform
i thought like last night doc rivers i
thought stole the show
i thought he was amazing just the
emotion
you know dan i like i say i'm never
going to tell anybody they're right or
wrong the way they want to protest
but i'm not sure how sitting out a game
uh boycotting the game would have
effect on the situation you know we need
uh police reform
we need prison reform those are two
things we really need
you know i talked about it last night on
the show i said you know i'm
disappointed
that because bad cops are making it
unsafe
for the good cops that's what that's
what what i i said last night if all the
good cop that most of the cops agree
i don't care what anybody says i think
most of the cops are great
but they're making it unsafe for the
good cops the bad cops
and i'm disappointed in the police union
uh i think the police need to get
together and get rid of their union to
be honest with you because they're
making it unsafe for the good cops
uh we need cops if it wasn't for the
cops i mean
everybody calls the cops when things are
bad but we have some cops who shouldn't
be cops
uh my my bodyguard is a cop for 30 years
his wife was a cop for 30 years
shout out to james haywood and he talks
we talk about it all the time because i
always get his opinion on
on these shootings uh and he always say
hey he'll tell me when the cops are
right
he'll tell me when the cops are wrong
and uh
so this clearly was a you know the
shooter guy in the back with kids in the
car
uh you know i know that was an
altercation beforehand which
i'm not sure i'm not sure what's going
on with the media they did not show us
the altercation
in advance there was an altercation in
advance
uh before he went to his car they
haven't showed us that
but that being said i think there's a
fight gotta find a way to de-escalate
the situation
without shooting a guy in the back seven
times with his kids in the car
yeah and unarmed and unarmed
yeah but uh you know i think you have to
really be careful there dan like i said
i know he was an arm but
you know if you get in a fight with
somebody and they go to their car that's
a really scary situation
but there's got to be a better way to
shoot the guy seven times in the back
with his kids in the car
good to visit with you uh you got
thunder rockets
magic bucks blake uh blazers lakers
you excited you know dan this has turned
into like a real job we work
every day it's like
ncaa tournament yeah but that's only a
couple days
you know working you know dan i'm 57
i've never worked
every day in my life this is not this is
no joke i
hey i'm starting to like you at the
nerds a lot more now it's like
man how do y'all get up and go to work
every day this is no joke
i don't know how people don't get up
every day and go to work
well they call professional player
players they're called jocks we don't go
to work every day
are you playing golf today no man the
weather has been
awful in atlanta you know we're in a
bubble in atlanta
it has rain every day for you know we
getting the remnants of those two
hurricanes
so it has rain every day for a week and
it's gonna rain every day for another
week
because like i say we're not in the path
of the hurricane but we're getting the
the side effects have you had shack out
playing golf
no no no no shaq is he's too busy
smoking hookah
to play golf wait
do you have a video of shaq smoke on his
hookah
shaq does hookah every single day dan he
loves hookah
you know i've been i've been a couple
times because i'm not a big huckle guy
but he loves his hookah man he loves it
what kind of feeling does it give you
you know uh it didn't do anything for me
i don't know how it affects other people
it didn't do anything for me it's kind
of like when i smoked pot
i smoked pot like five times in my life
and all it made me want to do is eat
potato chips
like i got a couple homeboys who love
pot and smoke it all the time
i've tried about five times in my life
and like i say all it makes me want to
do is eat potato chips
you don't need pot to do that no no but
i'm saying
like i love potato chips obviously like
most people do but
you know i tried to be like one of my
boys like yo man try this try this
and i tried and i'm like it didn't make
me feel no type of way
i'm like yo man it just makes me hungry
it's kind of like yoga
like yoga i've done yoga before they're
like well don't they take you to a
different place i'm like nah it don't do
anything for me
i feel like i'm stretching no it doesn't
free my mind or anything
it just makes me feel like i'm
stretching
good to visit with you and uh man thanks
for joining us
thank you for having me hi buddy that's
charles barkley